[Music]
there is one big star who is definitely
not a big fan of The Bachelor Nick vile
so why is William Shatner begging people
to get Nick kicked off of Dancing with
the Stars
[Music]
Shatner's no Nik campaign started before
the live show even premiered on Monday
when he took to Twitter and declared
quote my goal for a hashtag DWTS is to
knock bachelor nick out ASAP
who was with me the actor who turns 86
today tweeted over 20 times during an
after the show urging fans to vote for
anyone but Nick wanting him gone next
week
now Shatner has never competed on the
show himself but he has a big fan of the
series even appearing in a video to
cheer on season 20 contestant Noah
Galloway watch Noah Galloway keep trying
and get better and better unbelievable
but why is Shatner so anti NIC saying
quote she lives up to the hominem of his
last name
it might go back to 2014 when Nick first
appeared on The Bachelor franchise and
infamously called out bachelorette Andi
Dorfman if you weren't in love with me
I'm like why you made love a pic I don't
that's where Shatner says Nick quote
started the Spile journey meanwhile Nick
had a simple response to Shatner's
anyone but Nick crusade a single sad
face emoji Nick's damn partner probe
Peta Murgatroyd also tweeted out crying
emojis I have a great partner PETA if
I'm lucky enough to stick around I think
hopefully it's gonna be fun for you know
American or what here's the crazy thing
even Tom Bergeron is getting involved in
this hi you yeah the host of Dancing
with the Stars posted this message today
happy birthday to my pal at William
Shatner any chance I can negotiate the
truth between you and vile Nicholas
twenty-eight Tom Bergeron the
peacemaking you can't say no to talk can
you
[Music]